yeah the visual system is amazing we're
mostly visual animals to navigate
survive humans mainly rely on vision not
smell or something else but
um it's a filter for cognition
and it's a it's a strong driver of
cognition
maybe just because it came up and then
we're moving to higher level concepts
just the the way the visual system works
can be summarized in it
um in a few relatively succinct
statements unlike most of what i've said
which has not been succinct at all let's
go there um
the retina that's involved yeah so the
retina is this
three layers of neuron structure at the
back your eyes about as thick as a
credit card
it is a piece of your brain and
sometimes people
think i'm kind of wriggling by out of a
reality by saying that it is it's
absolutely a piece of the brain it's
it's a forebrain structure that in the
first trimester there's a genetic
program
that made sure that that neural retina
which is part of your central nervous
system was squeezed out into what's
called the embryonic eye cups
and that the bone formed with a little
hole where the optic nerve is going to
connect it to the rest of the brain and
those
that window into the world is the only
window into the world for a for a mammal
which has a thick skull birds have a
thin skull so their pineal gland
sits and lizards too and snakes actually
have a hole so that light can make it
down into the pineal directly and in
train melatonin rhythms for time of day
and time of year
humans have to do all that through the
eyes so three layers of neurons
that are a piece of your brain their
central nervous system and the optic
nerve
connects to the rest of the brain the
neurons in the eye
some just care about luminance just how
bright or dim it is
and they inform the brain about time of
day and then the central circadian clock
informs every cell in your body about
time of day
and make sure that all sorts of good
stuff happens if you're getting light in
your eyes at the right times
and all sorts of bad things happen if
you are getting light randomly
throughout the 24 hour cycle we could
talk about all that
but this is a good incentive for keeping
a relatively normal schedule
a consistent schedule light exposure
consistent schedule try and keep a
consistent schedule when you're young
it's easy to go off schedule and recover
as you get older it gets harder but you
see everything from
outcomes in cancer patients to um
diabetes you know improves when people
are getting light at particular time of
day and getting darkness at a particular
phase
of the 24-hour cycle we were just
designed to
um get light and dark at different times
of this
of the circadian cycle that's all being
all that information is coming in
through
specialized type of neuron in the retina
called the melanopsin intrinsically
photosensitive ganglion cell discovered
by
david berson at brown university
that's not spatial information it's
subconscious you don't think oh it's
daytime even if you're looking at the
sun it doesn't matter it's a photon
counter
it's literally counting photons and it's
saying oh even though it's a cloudy day
lots of photons coming in at
winter in boston it must be winter and
your system is a little depressed it's
spring you feel alert that's not a
coincidence that's these melanopsin
cells signaling the circadian clock
there are a bunch of other neurons in
the eye
that signal to the brain and they mainly
signal the presence of
things that are lighter than background
or darker than background so
a black object would be dark in the
background a light object
lighter than background and that all
come it's mainly a pic it's looking at
pixels mainly it's
they look at circles and those neurons
have receptive fields which
not everyone will understand but those
neurons respond best to little circles
of dark light or little circles of
bright light little circles of red light
versus
little circles of green light or blue
light and
so it sounds very basic it's like red
green blue
and circles brighter or dimmer than
what's next to it
but that's basically the only
information that's sent down the optic
nerve
and when we say information we can be
very precise i don't mean little bits of
red traveling down the optic nerve i
mean
spikes neural action potentials in space
and time
which for you is like makes total sense
but i think for a lot of people
it's it's actually beautiful to think
about
all that information in the outside
world is converted into a language
that's very simple it's just like a few
syllables
if you will and those syllables are
being shouted
down the optic nerve converted into a
totally different language like morse
code
goes into the brain and then the
thalamus essentially responds in the
same way that the retina does
except the thalamus is also weighting
things it's saying
you know what that thing um was moving
faster than everything else
or it's brighter than everything else so
that signal i'm going to get up
i'm going to allow up to cortex or
that signal is much redder than it is
green so i'm going to let that signal go
through that signal is much
er it's kind of more like the red next
to it
throw that out the information just
doesn't get up into your cortex and then
in cortex of course is where perceptions
happen
and in v1 if you will visual area one
but also some neighboring areas you
start getting
representations of things like oriented
lines so there's a neuron that responds
to this
angle of my hand versus vertical right
this is the defining work of human
beings nobel
and it's a very systematic map of
orientation line orientation
direction of movement and so forth and
that's pretty much end color
and that's how the visual system is
organized all the way up to the cortex
so it's hierarchical you don't build i
want to be clear it's hierarchical
because you don't build up that line by
suddenly having a neuron that responds
to lines
in a some random way it responds to
lines by taking all the dots that are
aligned in a vertical stack
and they all converge on one neuron and
then that neuron responds to vertical
lines so it's not random
there's no abstraction at that point in
fact in fact if i
showed you a black line i could be sure
that if i were imaging v1 that i would
see a representation of that black line
as a vertical line
somewhere in your cortex so at that
point
it's absolutely concrete it's not
abstract
but then things get really mysterious
some of that information travels further
up into the cortex so that
and goes from one visual area to the
next to the next to the next
so that by time you get into an area
that um nancy can wish her at mit
has studied her much of her career the
fusiform face area
you start finding single neurons that
respond only
to your father's face or to joe rogan's
face
regardless of the orientation of his
face i'm sure if you saw joe
because you know him well from across
the room and you just saw his profile
be like oh that's joe walk over and say
hello
the orientation of his face isn't there
you wouldn't even see his eyes
necessarily
but he's represented in some abstract
way by a neuron that actually would be
called the joe rogan neuron
or he might show neurons it might have
limits like i might not recognize him if
he was upside down or something like
that
it'd be fascinating to to see what the
limits of that joe rogan concept is
so nancy's lab has done that because
early on she was challenged by people
that said there aren't
face neurons there are neurons that they
only respond to space and time
shapes and things like that moving in
particular directions and orientations
and it turns out
nancy was right they used these stimuli
called grieble stimuli which
any computer programmer would appreciate
which kind of morphs a face into
something
gradually that eventually just looks
like this like alien thing they call the
grebel
and the neurons don't respond to grebels
in most cases
they only respond to faces and familiar
faces anyway i'm summarizing a lot of
literature and forgive me nancy and for
those of the grieble people
if there are anything like you don't
come after me with pitchforks
actually you know what come on
pitchforks i think you know what i'm
trying to do here yeah
so the point is that in the visual
system it's very concrete up until about
visual area four which has color
pinwheels and seems to respond to
pinwheels of colors and
um and so the stimuli become more and
more elaborate
but at some point you depart that
concrete representation and you start
getting abstract representations that
can't be explained by simple
point-to-point wiring
and to take a leap out of the visual
system to the higher level concepts what
we talked about in the visual system
maps to the auditory system where you're
encoding what
frequency of tone sweeps so it's gonna
sound weird to do but you know
uh like a doppler like hearing something
a car passing by for instance but at
some point
you get into motifs of music that can't
be mapped to just a
a what they call a tonatopic map of
frequency
you start abstracting and if you start
thinking about concepts
of creativity and love and memory like
what is the map of memory space right
well
your memories are very different than
mine but presumably there's enough
structure at the early stages of memory
processing or at the early stages of
emotional processing
or at the earlier stages of creative
processing
that you have the building blocks your
zeros and ones if you will
but you depart from that eventually
now the exception to this and i want to
be really clear because i was just
mainly talking about neocortex
the six layered structure on the outside
of the brain that explains a lot of
human abilities other animals have them
too
is that subcortical structures are a lot
more like machines
it's more plug and chug and
what i'm talking about is the machinery
that controls heart rate and breathing
and receptive fields um you know neurons
that respond to things like
temperature on the top of my left hand
and one of the
you know i came into neuroscience from a
more of a perspective
initially of psychology but one of the
reasons i forced
upon myself to learn some
electrophysiology
not a ton but enough and some molecular
biology and about circuitry
is that one of the most beautiful
experiences you can have in life
i'm convinced is to lower an electrode
into the cortex and to show a person or
an animal you do this ethically of
course
a stimulus yes like an oriented line or
a face
and you can convert the recordings
coming off of that electrode into an
audio signal
an audio monitor and you can hear what
they call hash it's not the hashy smoke
it's the hashy here
and it's it sounds like
it just sounds like noise and in the
cortex eventually you find a stimulus
that gets the neuron to spike and fire
action potentials that are converted
into an auditory stimulus
that are very concrete crack crack crack
sounds like a bat cracking you know like
home runs you know or
outfield balls when you drop electrodes
deeper
into the thalamus or into the
hypothalamus or into the brain stem
areas that control breathing
it's like a machine you never hear hash
you drop the electrode down this could
be
like a like a grungy old tungsten
electrode
not high fidelity electrode as long as
it's got a little bit of insulation on
it you plug it into an audio monitor
it's picking up electricity
and if it's a visual neuron and it's in
the thalamus or the retina and you walk
in front of
that animal or person that that neuron
goes
and then you walk away and it stops and
you put your hand in front of the
eye again and it goes ah and you could
do that
for two days and that neuron will just
every time there's a stimulus it fires
so whereas before it's a question of how
much information is getting up to cortex
and then these
abstractions happening where you're
creating these ideas
when you go subcortical everything is
there's no abstraction it's two plus two
equals four there's no abstraction
you